Listen, I don't know if you guys saw it, but Pam Bondi
Pam Bondi was in front of the Senate Judiciary Committee today
and there are some actually pretty good highlights from it. Okay.
She ends up talking about the Tom Hman stuff. She talks about
a lot of that's going on in the in the Justice Department. Talks
about a lot of
Uh I was told it was judiciary today. Peter Prosperity.
What? I even looked I looked it up.
It's oversight.
No. No, it's not oversight, is it? Or is this an old article?
No.
Senate Judiciary Committee hearing.
It says Senate Judiciary Committee hearing. What are you guys
doing? What are you What are you saying?
Senate Judiciary on Tuesday. Today's
All right, we'll be we'll be watching for any future Hassan updates.
What are we going to do with the Twitch? I think we're going
to end the Twitch for the day, guys. Okay, head over to
All right, we're we're going to be over there. We're live there.
Love you guys. Uh but I want to go and move on to some politics
stuff. And then after a little bit of politics stuff, we're going
to head into the what is it? The the Destiny docks. Okay, new
Destiny docks today. They got redacted versions for some of the
ones that came out just today, but All right.
Twitch stream is offline, guys. If you like the content, go ahead,
follow on every platform,
join the Discord.
All right. On Twitch and Twitter, it's JSTLK on Kick Patreon.
Everywhere else, it's just JSLK.
All right. If you really like the content, you want to add some
more time to the stream, you can donate. You can sub on kick,
you can sub on Twitch, you give subs at either place, you can
buy a TTS message, exclamation point, donate in the chat. We'll
give you the links to do that. All right. Every dollar through
these through these donation methods goes more time on the stream.
There's also kick
what is it? Kick kicks. You can donate kicks. They're the kick
equivalent of bits. Love those. We've got a meter for them on
the stream.
Yeah. Thank you guys. Appreciate all the
Let's uh let's check out some of this Senate Judiciary Committee
hearing. The Democrats this time.
To hear Oh, the Durban. The Durban questioning was pretty good.
>> Senator Durban.
>> Let's go. Durban, step it up to the >> Thanks,
Mr. Chairman. Uh Madam Attorney General, let me ask you this.
>> Buckmary Trump Vance MTG. No >> question. Were
you consulted by the White House >> before they deployed
>> National Guard?
>> Yo, King Jones 112, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
you, buddy. >> Troops to cities in the United States.
>> I am not going to discuss any internal conversations
with the White House.
>> You won't even say whether you talk to the White House
about this. >> I am not going to discuss any internal conversations
with the White House with you, chair um ranking member. I noticed
that. What's the secret? Why do you want to keep this secret?
The American people don't know the rationale behind the deployment
of National Guard troops in my state. The word is, and I think
it's been confirmed by the White House, they are going to transfer
Texas National Guard units to the state of Illinois. What What's
the rationale for that? Yeah, chairman, as you shut down the
government, you voted to shut down the government and you're
>> how many times just I want to point out how insanely
norming that in and of itself is, okay, that you have an overtly
partisan attorney general,
right?
Like that is already crazy. That is already something that is
totally unacceptable by the norms of this country. It's already
totally
And she just immediately goes to, "Yeah, uh, you guys shut down
the government." And I'm just going to I'm going to say it all.
It's just, it's actually nuts. >> They're sitting here.
>> But Biden Oh, the other thing we have to do is we have
to look at the Arctic Frost investigation and see what we can
figure out there. Okay? Because if you guys haven't if you guys
have missed it, I believe Chuck Grassley just put out some documents
that show that the FBI and under Jack Smith and his election
interference investigation. They tapped the phones or maybe not
even tap the phones, but they were tracking the calls of a few
members of the Republican Senate, right? And so they're saying
that this was like illegal spying or this is totally spying.
I don't think that that's necessarily the case, though. Like
to me, it's like, okay, well, they think you're trying to overthrow
the government. Yeah, they're probably going to track who you're
calling. Like if you're outwardly going, "No, no, no. This wasn't
an insurrection, and they know it was." Yeah, they're probably
going to track your phone calls or something. I would >> our
law enforcement officers aren't being paid. They're out there
working to protect you. I wish you love Chicago as much as you
hate President Trump. And currently, the National Guard are on
the way to Chicago. If you're not going to protect your citizens,
President Trump
>> been on this committee for more than 20 years. That's
the kind of testimony you expect from this administration. the
legal rationale.
>> I love that it comes out from Durban as well. Like it's
just it's obvious what's going on, right? Hey, this is literally
just a cult member. They've sent a cult member to testify. They
have a they have a major role in the US government for being
a cult member. >> For deploying National Guard troops becomes
grounds for personal attack. I think it's a legitimate question.
>> Oh, don't say personal attack. Partisan attack. Partisan
attack. this supposedly
assumably independent judiciary is sorry not even judiciary um
uh what is it executive
executive executive what do you call the the attorney general
this
this head of one of the branches of the executive is coming out
here they're supposed to be totally nonpartisan and she's actually
just doing partisan attacks for Trump >> question it's
my responsibility
she refuses to answer as to whether she had any conversation
with the White House about deploying national troops to my state.
That's an indication. >> Do you call the attorney general
a cabinet secretary? I didn't think you did, but maybe maybe
they are considered a part of the cabinet. Maybe that's an appropriate
secondary title. >> I'm afraid where we are politically
in this place. Let me ask you another question. I want to uh
if you will hold on a second,
make sure I got the right page of facts here.
You testified under oath when you last before this committee
that before
uh your appointment to attorney general >> you had served
as representative of some sort for >> Wait wait this has
got to be I'm almost positive cuz so many of these people have
to go hey what happened to that list that was sitting on your
desk now that you're like on the record didn't you say there
was a list sitting on your desk like an Epstein client list that
you were about to sign off on being released >> the royal
family of cutter
There was an issue that came before you in May when President
Trump accepted a $400 million luxury jet from the royal family
of cutter for temporary use as Air Force One before it's permanently
gifted gifted to the Trump Presidential Library Foundation. The
Constitution unequivocally bestows on Congress the power to control
whether any officer of the United States, including the president,
may accept a gift, quote, from any king, prince, or foreign state.
End of quote. And this gift clearly violates the statutory regime
enacted by Congress. You've refused to answer a letter I sent
to you five months ago asking the legal rationale you relied
on to advise President Trump to accept this unprecedented gift
from your former uh legal client. Can you make a promise today
that you will disclose that?
>> Disclose what ranking member?
>> Oh, I don't know if you guys remember. Oh, hold on.
I assume there was a letter or some sort of statement from your
office to the White House to advise them that you felt it was
permissible
>> first to address my role with cutter.
>> Did you did you as the head of
as the head of the Department of Justice? Did you feel the need
to like doublech checkck the corruption possibilities or yeah
corruption possibilities on this? Or did you say that oh I don't
find you guys corrupt for this reason or did you just not look
at it? You understand corruption is like your purview, right?
You're the department of justice. It's your purview. How did
you not look into >> As I addressed with you during my
confirmation hearing, I disclosed it in my SJQ
in private practice. I worked for a cutter for antihuman trafficking
for the World Cup. That was my only involvement and I made that
very clear and I'm very proud of everything I've done with antihuman
trafficking. Obviously, in preparing any advice for >> Okay,
interesting. She also works for the president on a jet or anything
else, we consult with the office of legal counsel. The confidentiality
applies to their input as well. And chairman, if you would approve
and vote to approve, as Chairman Grassley said, excuse me, ranking
member, as chairman Grassley said, my employees, we would answer
your letters a lot faster. Yet, you're stalling them at every
stop. And to go back to your previous question,
your city has a murder rate five times higher than New York's.
>> So, she's literally just here to do Trump propaganda
instead of answering questions, right? She's going to take every
time she's asked a question, she's going to do Trump propaganda
instead of answering the question.
homicides
last year. If you were serious about protecting your people,
you would be asking this administration for help. You're you're
saying that we're coming into your state and your city. We're
there to help make America safe and Illinois safe whether or
not you want
>> I believe cutting federal grant programs to law enforcement
in my state and across the nation does not make us any safer
and you've done just that. You've supplanted that decision by
sending in National Guard troops to California and other places.
Uh that is a situation where the governors have not asked for
that help. If you truly wanted to do this on a bipartisan basis,
you wouldn't defy a governor. You would work with them. I'm prepared
to do that. I'm prepared to work with this administration. But
cutting these grants to law enforcement does not make us any
stronger as a nation or give us the tools we need to reduce crime
in Chicago. Now, I'd just like to ask you, >> when it came
to this cutter situation, did you consult with the ethics office
in the Department of Justice before making your decision on this
gift of a
Chairman, I didn't gift a jet to anyone.
>> Yeah. No.
can we just talk about how like catastrophically
you have to be to respond that way to a question as if you don't
understand what he's talking
>> My office of legal counsel provides confidential advice
to the president, to the White House. Period.
And you're conflating two issues. Cutting grants. I was very
clear about what grants we've cut and what grants we haven't.
Only 7%. And if you have a grant in Illinois that you think that
I've cut that is not protect that is protecting law enforcement
officers or your people, you personally call me and I will work
with you to turn that grant back on. I think many of the Democrats
here can tell you I have worked with them to turn grants back
on. There's an appeal process. Tell me a specific grant that
I have turned off.
Like, okay.
I I didn't even realize this has been a thing. There's like grants
for law enforcement that they're cutting from, I assume, blue
places only. And and then she's like, uh, we have to send the
National Guard in now cuz you guys aren't doing your job
>> in Illinois that would help law enforcement and I will
work with you, but you have not done that. Did you take a look?
The National Guard is on the way right now as we speak. Oh, by
the way, so is Director Patel and Deputy Attorney General Todd
Blanch. You're sitting here grilling me and they are on their
way to Chicago to keep your state safe.
>> listen. I'm going to send the most incompetent members
of the Justice Department to your state so you feel safer. Okay?
Literally, we only have incompetence now. We got Cash Patel.
This guy managed to take a public tip and botch an investigation.
Okay? He he was totally botching the investigation into Charlie
Kirk's assassination and then he got a public tip gifting him
it and he still lost all public approval.
Cash Patel
is the most Listen, Cash Patel may be the most unlikable person
in the government right now, which is saying something. All right,
>> attorney general, it's my job to grill
The investigation of your agency is part of my responsibility
and this this uh committee. You may not like the experience,
but others have weathered this storm and answered questions.
>> No, Stephen Miller is you're right. You're right. >> Respectful
manner. >> Can you tell me the grants ranking member, please?
>> Take a look at the president's budget on Haida grants.
What happens to it in his proposed budget? >> I'd be glad
to meet with you on the >> It's cut by onethird
from $300 million to 196. That's one example of a grant that
works and your administration has suggested cutting it in and
the budget lies ahead. I want to ask you about an items in a
letter I sent you in July that you have uh not answered. In February,
you made a public claim that the Epstein client list was quote
sitting on my desk right now for
>> Thank you. Thank you, Senator Durban. That's the one
I wanted to hear about. Why did this dumb say she has the Epstein
client list sitting on her desk and she's just waiting for the
approval to release it? And now now she said you're like, "Well,
I don't know that there is a I don't even know that this guy
trafficked anybody." >> End of quote. You then produced
already public information and no client list at a major media
event hosted at the White House. Attorney General Bondi, why
did you publicly claim to have the Epstein CL client list waiting
for your review and then produced nothing relevant to that claim?
>> Senator Der Senator Durban, if you listen to my entire
clip on that, I said I had not reviewed it yet, that it was sitting
on my desk along with the JFK files, the Martin Luther King.
Okay.
Does she Does she not Hey, if you reviewed the whole clip, I
say it was sitting on my desk, but I hadn't reviewed it yet.
Okay. The idea that it was sitting on your desk means it's a
thing that you are aware of that you are identifying. Hey, it's
a list of his
He didn't ask you why didn't you name these people directly,
right? He said, why did you say that it was sitting on your desk
and now you say it doesn't
Well, I you know, I hadn't reviewed it. I just had papers sitting
on my desk and I kind of assumed that they were an Epstein client
list but actually it was just some menus for pizza places in
DC and you know that's on me that's on me files and I said I
had not yet reviewed it and if you see our memo on Epstein you
will see excuse me our memo on Epstein clearly points out that
there was no client list our July 6th memo you also didn't let
me respond to the Haida
>> she said client list I believe she responded directly
about the client list Mr. The budget transfers $196 million for
highintensity drug trafficking areas to the Office of Justice
Programs, OJP. The Justice Department will continue to administer
those grants under OJ in
Going back to the Epstein files, uh, according to another whistleblower
who made a protected disclosure to my office, you pushed the
FBI to review approximately a 100,000 Epstein related records
on an arbitrarily short deadline in March, and the FBI was directed
to flag any documents that mentioned President Trump. Nothing
came of that review until July when DOJ and FBI released an unsigned
memo stating, quote, "There's no incriminating client list."
Why was the July 7th memo
The July 7th memo came from the FBI and the Department of Justice.
Director Patel answered those questions very clear. And >> uh
Soapbox Society, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it.
>> You know, Senator Durban, I I find it very interesting
that you refused repeated Republican requests to release the
Epstein flight logs in 2023 and 2024. You fought that. I did
you take money from Reed Hoffman campaign donations, who was
a huge Epstein friend? Why did you fight for years? Did Why did
you fight to not
original clip saying it's on her desk. Hold on.
Let's take a look. Let's take a look. >> The DOJ may be
releasing the list of Jeffrey Epstein's clients. Will that really
happen? >> It's sitting on my desk right now to review.
Um, that's been a directive by
>> Well,
oh, soapbox Society, thank for the five gifted. Let's go.
Okay. So, are you going to release the Epstein client list? Yeah,
it's sitting on my desk right now. It's right now. It's sitting
on my desk. >> President Trump, I'm reviewing that. I'm
reviewing JFK files, MLK files. That's all in the process of
being reviewed because that was done at the directive of the
president from all of these >> So, so have you. >> Wow.
Wow. Wow. >> Seen anything that you said, "Oh my
>> Okay. Apparently, this is a widespread problem on the
right. Okay. She's like, "I haven't reviewed any of this." He's
like, "Have you seen anything that made you go wow?"
You She just said she didn't reve Brother, she did. You just
misunderstand what she was saying.
>> Okay. Oh. >> Uh, with disclose the um the flight
log, Senator Durban, >> I can tell you I did not refuse.
One of the senators here wished to produce those logs and I asked
her to put it in writing and she never did. >> Yeah, I
think Senator Leperin would quarrel with you on that. >> I
will quarrel with you as to read somebody that you mentioned
I never heard of to President Trump.
to flag records for President Trump. >> To flag any records
which included his
>> I'm not going to discuss anything about that with you,
Senator. >> Eventually, you're going to have to answer
for your conduct in this. You won't do it today, but eventually
you will. I yield, Mr. Chairman. >> I got Mr. Chairman
something here, >> Mr. Chairman.
>> Mr. Chairman.
>> Okay, I'm going to go to the next one.
Okay, we're going to do one more
>> one more set of questions here and then possibly switch.
I'll see when I want to switch. Okay, but we're going to do the
we're going to do the the new legal rulings at probably right
after this. Okay, coming up.
>> Thank you, chairman. >> This is this is a big
one cuz it's going to go people are going to ask her about the
Tom Hman [__] which to me is absolutely passive.
>> Miss Bonnie, good morning.
>> Good morning. What became
of the
in cash
that the FBI paid to
Mr. Homeman in a >> paper bag evidently
>> a shopping bag from the chain Cava. Okay. This guy accepted
$50,000 in cash in a shopping bag.
And when asked about it on Fox News, all he said was, "I did
nothing illegal." So, so he gets asked about it. Hey, did you
keep that money? I did nothing illegal. I did I did absolutely
nothing illegal.
Or wait, I think he says, "I did nothing criminal." Actually,
technically, hello. >> Senator, as Deputy Attorney General
Todd Blanch recently stated, the investigation of Mr. Homeman
was subjected to a full review by the FBI. That's not what we
asked. He said, "What became of the money?" Okay. Subjected to
a full review. Cool story, bro. What happened to the money? Am
I keep the >> Agents and DOJ prosecutors, they found no
credible evidence of any wrongdoing. >> And that was that's
no credible evidence of wrongdoing under a criminal standard
or under an ethical standard. Is this an ethical standard that
you you you know, do you hold everybody in your administration
to this ethical standard where hey, if you can find a legal way
to take bribe money, even though we can obviously identify the
ethical lapses, uh that's fine. Just figure out a legal way to
do it. Is that the is that the ethic? Is that the um is that
the character of the Trump administration?
Would you say >> that was not my question. My question
was what became of the $50,000 in cash that the FBI delivered
evidently in a now she is a robot so she won't even though she
gets the correction that that was not an answer to the question
she is a robot so she will say it again or she'll talk about
you guys defunded the government or she'll talk about some other
Trump propaganda point okay >> paper bag >> totally
mentally broken this woman is >> to Mr. Hman.
>> Senator, I'd look at your facts.
>> The fact is we have credible reporting that he accepted
$50,000 in a in a grocery bag. So if I look at the facts, then
he took the money and that's how I will judge this entire administration
going forward. Thank you. >> Are you saying that they did
not deliver $50,000 in cash to Mr. Holman? >> Senator,
as recently stated, the investigation of Mr. Hman was subjected
to a full review. >> Actual Marco Rubio moment again >> by
the FBI agents
>> by Department of Justice prosecutors.
They found no evidence of wrongdoing. >> That's a different
question. What >> I feel like these guys have to start
demonstrating how the idea that he hasn't done anything wrong
doesn't mean he didn't take the $50,000.
Right. It might be that you can't charge him for accepting that
$50,000 because you can't prove that he's provided services or
you or he didn't have the job yet, right? That he was accepting
it under the prospect under the understanding that he would have
the job eventually.
But that that it would still obviously be an ethical lapse to
take that
And that's what we all assume happened because of exactly because
of how Pam Bondi is answering the question. >> Became of
the $50,000.
Did the FBI get it back? >> Mr. White House. Excuse me.
Senator White House, you're welcome to talk to the FBI.
>> The report to you. Can't you answer this >> Senator
White House, you're welcome to discuss this with Director Patel.
>> So, she obviously has the authority. She is the direct
the FBI director's boss, right? She has every authority to do
it this way. >> The $50,000.
As Deputy Attorney General Todd Blanch recently stated, the investigation
of >> Never mind. I can see I'm not going to get a straight
answer from you to >> like these people should start verbally
abusing her like calling her too stupid to answer the question.
Not int how can you possibly be intelligent enough to run the
the entire DOJ to be the attorney general of the United States
and you can't understand that you refuse to answer this question.
They should start verbally berating her because it is what she
has earned by being a [__]
>> Very simp
>> like there's no there's no way to if you just if you
maintain decorum here you are being dishonest. It is actually
dishonest to treat this person like a regular human being worthy
of respect. It's completely dishonest. >> And the DOJ
they found no credible evidence of wrongdoing. You know you're
very concerned about money and people taking money and you rail
against dark money. Wait a second. You work with dark money.
groups all the time. Senator,
>> uh, you're worried about this guy accepting bribes,
but you accept dark money for your for your campaigns and
>> Did you know
whether or not in that investigation they looked at whether the
2024 $50,000 payment to Mr. Hman
was declared by him on his tax returns?
Senator, I >> no evidence of wrongdoing. >> I would
be more concerned if I >> Now, here's the real question.
Okay. If he didn't declare it in time, if he didn't declare it
directly, but he updates his tax returns like Hunter Biden did,
will there be a similar investigation? Probably not cuz it's
within a certain time frame, right? I think I think Hunter was
late or something, but it'd be very interesting to know. you
when you talk about corruption and money that you that when you
pushed for legislation that would subsidize your wife's company,
>> the um
questions here are actually pretty specific.
So having you respond with completely
far-right internet talking points really is not >> ah you
should you dude I it's like not bad but he should point out that
she is corrupt that she is supporting a corrupt administration
that she will be held responsible right you are you are upholding
you are sweeping you are covering for a corrupt administration
and we will uncover everything and you will spend the rest of
your life in prison. I promise you, I will make it my mission
for the rest of my time in Congress to make sure that every bit
of corruption from this administration is rooted out and every
single person responsible is prosecuted.
>> Very helpful here. I'd like, Mr. Chairman, you generally
like to have us be able to get answers
to know and we'll follow up with the QFR
and to the extent Patel wants to answer, that would be great
as well. What happened to the
Did Hman keep it?
Did the FBI get it back? If he kept it, did he put it on his
tax returns? Pretty simple
Um, Hman was the same guy who said there was a deal with Eric
Adams. He said, "If Adams doesn't come through, I'll be back.
I'll be in his office up his butt saying, "Where the hell is
the agreement we came to?"
Which brings us to the
um OPR investigation of prosecutorial misconduct
by Amile Boie because he was also involved in that transaction.
>> What became of the OPR investigation of prosecutorial
misconduct by Amal Bo? >> Yeah. And Senator White House,
to correct you for one moment, that would be the honorable judge
Amal J. Bo III to >> Not Oh, now now we're respecting people.
Okay, you want to go back? So, I I'll I'll do that whole thing
for you. Okay, I'll show respect to that person if you want to
respect the fact that you're not answering my question. You want
to go back and answer my questions and not, you know, stand up
like a bot and just say whatever canned line you had like your
Marco Rubio frozen on stage in 2016. Okay, then we can do that.
>> At the time of this, he was uh an employee of the Department
of Justice. And what became of the OPR
>> It's all pending litigation.
Senator, I can't discuss pending litigation nor personnel matters.
publicly says when there is an investigation and at the end of
it they provide a summary. Why can't you say whether there is
an OPR investigation and whether if it's concluded there's a
>> Senator, I'm not going to discuss personnel matters,
>> even public ones.
>> Yeah, that's what I was going to say. Panda Rider. I
think it was because it's so recent, he won't actually be able
to uh to be like like his taxes could just be amended now. >> Senator,
I'm not going to discuss personnel matters.
>> So, um
Cash Patel told this committee
that his grand jury testimony
after immunization, after initially pleading the fifth was, and
I quote, sealed by the Department of Justice.
How and when and why was his testimony sealed and by whom?
>> Senator, I'm not going to discuss any testimony, especially
testimony that could be sealed with you. >> No, the question
is was it or was it not
>> Senator, I'm not going to discuss that with you.
>> Well, he also said that he worked with the Department
of Justice to have his transcript released. >> Like, I'm
pretty sure this is uh what is this like? Oh, was this like Pete
Hegith? Somebody came before Congress. Okay, somebody did this
before. I can't remember which one it was, but this happens sometimes
where it's like literally your call on whether or not this stuff
gets talked about. Like you are literally the top official responsible
for this.
You get to decide whether or not you're allowed to do this. You
are just But they like they defer a procedure. >> It's
like no, I defer a procedure on this. Was it sessions? I don't
think it was sessions. It was like this year
>> you treat this as treason? You should. These people
are actually just like trying to rob every dollar they can out
of your country, assuming it's going all going down the drain
and they'll never be held responsible. That's all they're trying
to do. These people are all just thieves
just robbing the wealth of your country and then they're all
going to flee as soon as they're as soon as this administration's
finished. >> And when was his transcript released? Presumably,
if he released it publicly, that's something you can discuss
because it's public. Well, Senator, I believe you discussed that
with Director Patel, >> and I'm asking you because he said
the Department of Justice
made this decision and you run the Department of Justice. >> I
would refer that to Director Patel. >> Even though you
run the Department of Justice and he testified that the Department
of Justice released his transcript publicly. >> If it is
released publicly, we will get you a copy, Senator. Gladly.
>> If being a rather important word there, when your FBI
director testified that that was a fact.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. I am thinking of that, but it
has to do with Pete Hegith,
right? It has to do with Pete Hegith and them trying to
They're trying to argue for why it wasn't a problem. They're
like, "Pegex has that authority." And it's like, "Yeah, but why
was he exerting that authority is a different thing." But you
are right. That's what it was about.
>> Released publicly, we will get you a copy, Senator.
Gladly.
>> If being a rather important word there, when your FBI
director testified that that was a fact. If my if my FBI director
isn't a total [__]
which I mean we both know he is, then then you can have the transcript.
But if he is a total [__] okay, you're not getting
that [__] cuz he lied to you. >> Treasury compiles
suspicious activity reports referred to often as SARS
that DOJ receives automatically.
Hundreds related to accounts of Jeffrey
How many of those Treasury SARS did you or Director Patel investigate?
>> Senator, I'm not sure if you're concerned because you
took money, I believe. Did you from Reed Hoffman, one of Epstein's
closest confidants, not only once but twice in 2018 and 2024,
if that's correct? But Senator,
did you
>> Senator? I'm not sure if you're concerned because you
took money. I >> Did she just did she just bring oppo research
for all of her? She just brought oppo research like Republican
oppo research for all of the people on this panel. >> Did
you from Reed Hoffman, one of Epstein's closest confidants, not
only once but twice in 2018 and 2024, if that's correct. >> But
Senator,
did you ask Merrick Garland any of this over the last four years
when he sat before you? >> Investigation has been going
on. This investigation was closed. Did you ask Alex the cost
of that? and Patel came to office. You said you would look into
this. There were hundreds of suspicious activity reports. Some
people would deduce from the fact that they are called suspicious
activity reports that there might be suspicious
activity. And yet you seem to have that zero of those suspicious
activity reports involving Jeffrey Epstein accounts. Let me ask
you something else. There's been public reporting that Jeffrey
Epstein showed people photos of President Trump with half naked
young women. Do you know if the FBI found those photographs in
their search of Jeffrey Epstein safe or premises or otherwise?
Have you seen any such thing? >> You know, Senator White
House, you sit here and make salacious remarks once again trying
to slander President Trump left and right when you're the one
who was taking money from one of Epstein's closest confidence.
I believe, I could be wrong, correct me, Reed Hoffman, who was
with Jeffrey Epstein on multiple occasions. And the senator sitting
right next to you, tried to block the flight logs from Wait,
hold on.
Okay, did he did he say this back? Cuz like if you're just going
to go into this Wait, does it is it a problem to be near Jeffrey
Epstein or
Cuz uh I don't know if you realize your boss was like best friends
with this guy. Lots of videos of them chuming it up together.
Like what are we what are we doing here Pam? >> I'm being
released. >> This is this is the sad thing is every single
one of these points they use now these people are are they have
nearly cart blanch with trying to
I guess redirect or or push away from like their problems but
they are so corrupt and so immoral that everything they use to
try to redirect to every single time they've already done themselves.
Every single time. Right. It's like, "Oh, well, don't you guys
hang out with Jeffrey Epstein?" It's like, "Brother, President
of the United States, the president of the United States is doing
this every single time, right?" It's like, "Dude, what are we
what is happening?" Like, you're using things that you are constantly
hitting your side with collateral damage. Are you saying it's
bad to associate with Jeff? Oh, apparently.
>> Yeah. You're grilling me on President Trump. some photograph
on Trump. >> The question is,
>> did the FBI find those photographs that have been discussed
publicly by a witness who claimed Jeffrey Epstein showed them
to him?
You don't know anything about that.
Okay.
Um,
here's what some Well, now we cut to something else. >> Uh,
as far as I can tell, Cosmo Cosmo, every time I looked up e-collars,
those are just electric collars.
>> like shot callers. >> The Marshall service is
supposed to protect our federal judges.
>> I have asked repeatedly
for the Marshall Service to let me know
if they are
or being inhibited from investigating
whether or not there is orchestration
of threats against federal judges.
>> Okay, I'm not as into this one. I'm gonna go. I think
we have Clolobachar. Clolobachar. Amy Clolobachar.
>> She eventually gets to talking about the Comey indictment.
I do want to see some of that. >> Clolobachar. You're recognized.
>> Thank you. But I think she starts attorney general Bondi.
Good morning. I'm going to start on different subject. Good morning.
>> On behalf of um families in my state. Could we at least
raise the age to 21 about that? Because I was going to ask you
if you received advice, instruction, or request from anyone at
the White House to direct the department to engage in any invest.
>> Okay. Okay. This is where we want to start off is with
the Comey question >> justice department and that America
would once again have a onetier
system of justice for all and that is what we are doing in this
country.
We saw this with the president direct >> I think I think
I got to go back >> talk about it later but that was my
question and you don't want to answer >> No, it's pending
litigation
purchase of an assault weapon federally while states look at
banning uh these weapons overall given these little babies. That
was my question. Your views on this is not pending litigation.
So I want to get to the independence of the Justice Department.
At your nomination hearing, I specifically ask you to provide
assurance to every member of this committee that the Justice
Department will only follow the facts in the law and the White
House will play no role in the cases investigated or brought.
You stated in respon response, this was you, politics will not
play a part in my decisions. And you also said the Justice Department
must be independent and must act independently.
Do >> Wow. It's almost like you came up before me when
when we were going to nominate you and you just like openly lied.
You just straight up lied. It's like obvious to everyone that
you lied. >> Do you believe that you have upheld that
>> I absolutely have upheld that commitment, Senator. I
pledged that I would end the weaponization also of the Justice
Department and that America
>> uh I ended the weaponization by weaponizing guys. Okay,
it turns out I I pledged to end the weaponization in the same
way that we ended Japan's weaponization. Okay,
all out nuclear strikes on our opponents. All right, that's that's
the only way. but once again have a onetier
system of justice for all and that is what we are doing in this
country.
We saw this with the president directing an investigation prosecution
of Chris Krebs, the former head of cyber security. Um, Lisa Cook,
former who is a current governor of the Federal Reserve, Director
Comey and the president, and I know you have said that you will
not discuss um dis discuss discussions you've had with the president
about Comey. Is that correct?
That you won't testify here about that? because I was going to
ask you if you received advice, instruction, or request from
anyone at the White House to direct the department to engage
in any investigations,
prosecutorial actions, including decisions not to investigate
or prosecute any discussion.
>> Can't Hussein go on October 7th without doing something
controversial?
>> Apparently not, Internet Explorer. Thank you for the
three >> conversations. But then how about the truth social
post on September 20th, 2025 in which the president said we can't
delay any longer.
How about how about the the all of the posts that the president
was doing explicitly telling you you have to go and indict these
people that you then indicted like that he knew he'd obviously
been advised by somebody that the statute of limitations for
Comey was coming up and then you guys rushed to indict him after
getting rid of the US attorney in the state that that eventually
when they were replaced their replacement indicted him. Like
you understand this is like very transparent to the American
people that you you had to let this guy step down so you could
put in Trump's again another
let's just say in in a year when you're when you've totally destroyed
your life Pam Bondi the woman Trump replaced you with in Virginia
is next up. Okay. Oh Lindsay Haligan. How how is it that these
women are all clones? It's like is Roger Als picking all legal
advisers for Trump? Is that who's doing it? It's it's got to
be Roger Als right? That's got to be who it is.
This is This is the next attorney general of the United States,
by the way. Lindseay Halligan.
And all I can think is, yeah, it's got to be like Roger Als or
some who's picking these people out.
I thought he hated
Oh, Roger Als might be dead. Okay. It's just It's like
blonde women. Blonde women lost plastic surgery.
Boom. This is your next attorney general of the United States.
Okay. Roger Hills is dead. I didn't know that. I saw some creepy
video with him not too long ago. Um, some creepy like I think
it was a recreation of him trying to like coers women into Yeah.
Gross, gross, gross.
Anyway, back to >> using your name, not bringing criminal
charges or our reputation, his words, and credibility.
and then goes on to tell you to prosecute a member of this committee,
to prosecute the attorney general of New York, and to prosecute
James Comey. Do you consider that a directive to the Justice
Department?
>> Senator Clolobashar, President Trump is the most transparent
president in American history. And I don't think he said anything
that he hasn't said for
>> Like I is How do you even respond? How do you even respond?
Hey, it has been reported that you initially pushed back against
report. >> He's the most he's the most transparent president
in history. When we ask you, hey, did you advise him of this
or that? Can you go on the record with this? You say, no, I cannot
go on the record with any any conversation I've had with the
White House. Probably because you realize anytime you've gone
on record with a conversation you had with the White House, Trump
immediately throws you under the bus, makes you look like a total
[__] right? he immediately goes out and like starts
publicly pressuring you to indict Comey or some something along
those lines, right? You'll say, "Oh, we had this conversation."
And he will totally throw you under the bus, make you look like
a [__] for saying that. for against requests by senior
Trump administration
officials um to push out or fire the acting US attorney in Virginia,
Eric Sabbert, who's a conservative Republican
um who made the decision that Comey that the evidence was not
there to prosecute Comey? What made you change your opinion?
>> I am not going to discuss personnel
>> Okay. Is it true that the career prosecutors in the
Eastern District of Virginia found that there was insufficient
evidence to bring criminal charges against former director Comey?
>> I am not going to discuss
>> Wait, hold on. Is she about to say she's not going to
discuss pending investigations?
Cuz she certainly did when it came to Tom Hman, right? Oh, well,
listen. We've we've made it public that this guy we found no
criminal >> pending cases because >> Oh, was indicted.
>> Oh, to be fair though, they did just totally dismiss
the Tom Homman case.
>> In the Eastern District of Virginia by, I may point
out, one of the most liberal grand juries in the country. >> Okay.
Let's go on to other firings or terminations. Last week, the
Justice Department fired at least two senior
the most liberal grand jury in the country. What is a liberal
grand jury? I
Hold on. I I actually don't know how they get grand juries together,
but
I I
Well, it's uh Oh, I see. I see. I see. So, it's Yeah, okay. Okay.
Because it's uh Well, although it was Virginia, it wasn't just
Would they have pulled just from DC?
Well, sorry. I know what the grand jur what a grand jury is,
but I thought you just do it the same way you do like jury duty.
Like you just pick citizens, right? Yeah. Okay.
>> Well, I think it's USDC Southern Virginia. USDC Virginia
>> in the Eastern District of Virginia. >> You signed
up for it. Okay. Okay. You signed up for it. So, it's different.
>> Including the office's national security chief, Michael
Bener.
It is >> I would just want to know how she makes that statement.
I I actually don't know. How do you make the statement? It's
the most liberal grand jury in the country. >> The office's
national security chief, Michael Beneri. It is reported that
his firing came following criticism from a right-wing social
media commentator who wrote, "One can only assume he was part
of the internal resistance in the Comey indictment. In fact,
he did not work on the Comey case. Instead, he was working on
pursuing justice for service members in Afghanistan."
How does firing a 20year national security prosecutor enhance
public
>> I'm not going to discuss hirings or firings.
She's just going to refuse to testify. She's going to refuse
to give testimony on like all of the things that actually matter.
>> Clover, I'm not going to discuss personnel decisions.
>> So disgusting. >> The personnel issue that I'm
having right now is that all of my agents, all of my lawyers
are working. My agents are on the street working without a paycheck
because your party voted to shut down the federal government.
Unfort
uh Marva dude, don't worry. We're going to get to the shift stuff
in just a little bit. Okay, we will get there and we'll we'll
cover all of that. But
you guys shut down the government again. Wait, I I forgot. Are
did Dems hold all the power right now? Is it is it a Dem majority
in the House now? I realize what is it to pass a budget you need
60 senators right that's the that's the
so any continuing any funding CR is going to require 60 senators
but still
>> but still >> forunately the house isn't even back
here they're 18 days off the job to even meet with us to come
up with a resolution that we would like to discuss with them
about saving people's healthcare let's move on to the antirust
division did you authorize your chief of staff to overrule of
top officials in the antitrust division to settle the challenge
to the Huelet Packard Enterprises Juniper Networks merger. Senator
Gail Slater runs my antitrust unit and she is doing an excellent
job on many many cases as you know that is a pending case. >> Okay.
In any merger, just to clarify, in any merger, Senator, there
is a
a deal struck with our office and with the corporations involved.
But then that also goes to a court to certify in any merger.
In any merger, it's a multi-step
>> Okay. I will ask some further stillending questions
about antitrust. I just had one other thing. DOJ
uh can now take the extraordinary step of subpoening journalists.
Has the Justice Department issued any subpoenas to journalists
under the updated guidance?
>> Time is expired. Okay, I'll ask those on the record.
>> Respond, Miss Bondi.
>> You can respond. She said,
"Senator, my office
in April restored the Justice Department's long-standing norm
on this issue. It was AG Garland who had deviated on the media
investigations
>> Okay, now I
that might be true. Maybe there there was no rule and then Garland
changed it or something. But I wonder what it was changed for
and and if it was really that far off the norm or if it was cementing
a norm. >> Allowing self-identified journalists
using the selfserving status as a shield against being held accountable
for endangering our nation's security. We have taken that policy
back to the norm. And I can't comment on whether we have or have
not or do or do not have pending
>> Okay, dude.
>> All right, let's see here. Let's um
what do we want to hop forward to? Shifty shift.
Let me see here.
Oh, I don't really want to though.
>> just more people are going to keep hitting over the
DOJ independent stuff. And I think the DOJ independent stuff
is like so important. I It happens to be something I think is
like it's incredibly important. Oh, wait. Hold on. DOJ attorney
who resigned speaks out as Bondi evades questions. Oh, what?
Let's >> I want to go now. Prime Minister Ryan Crosswell.
He is a former federal prosecutor who resigned after the DOJ
decided to drop corruption cases charges, I'm sorry, against
New York City Mayor Eric Adams. Ryan is now running as a Democrat
for a US House.
>> in the state of Pennsylvania. >> Okay, we will
we'll check this out shortly after. Um, this is going to be Senator
Blumenthal. We're going to watch this more just questions on
DOJ >> and people understand uh this issue of weaponization
of justice goes to the core of the integrity of our criminal
justice system. And I think we can all agree that no individual,
no group should be targeted simply because they are a political
opponent or because the president of the United States
has some personal animosity toward them. You've just said that
President Trump is the most transparent president in history,
tragically and chillingly.
You may be right when it comes to
>> uh spim do you have any evidence that this wouldn't
support like poorer people or like I would imagine this could
be for a ton of different income brackets you would say so pandemic
era premium healthcare credits it was over the premium healthcare
credits but I don't know that you have a lot of evidence or anyone
has a lot of evidence
of what income bracket this is like supporting mostly
>> criminal justice because far from ending
of justice. I would submit, Madam Attorney General, that President
Trump has embodied it and we have a record. It is a public record
of his express instructions
that certain individuals be investigated. The attorney general
of New York, Tis James, my colleague, Adam Schiff, the former
SISA director, Chris Krebs, the DHA,
>> like quick search. Okay, quick search. The premium tax
credits under the ACA most support individuals and families with
household incomes between 100 and 400% of the federal poverty
line. So it's basically above the poverty line to so middle class
to above middle class I would say. So you that's I would say
that's accurate.
Yeah. So income level from 125% to 400%
Sure. Yeah. It goes up to 400% of the poverty line. So this would
be a lot of the average people, right?
So the where would the poverty line be? I got to imagine the
poverty lines like
so in 2025 for example an individual must earn at least
15,000 to qualify and families of four must earn at least 31,000
to qualify.
Um and then I believe it's above that.
So above that, so anybody making under
any family of four making under $120,000
would benefit from those. So while we're using the poverty line
as a line there,
yeah, as well we're using the poverty line as the line there,
I do believe like income bracket wise, you end up in like the
lower average,
right?
Am I crazy? Up to $180,000 for families. I'm just looking at
it right now. It seems like in Florida or does it say in Florida?
No, no, no. 2025 for example, an individual must earn at least
15,000 and then a family of four must earn at least 31,000 to
qualify. Subsidy amount is on a sliding scale, generally larger
or incomes between 100 and 200% of the federal poverty line,
tapering off towards 400% of the federal poverty line. Above
400%, generally no premium tax credits are available under normal
rules. So for anybody making over 400% of what the poverty line
is.
So that that seems to me to be like for families and
that's that's not very high. That's not like for rich people.
That's not upper middle class. If you're a family of four making
180 grand that you're not even I I don't know that you're upper
middle class in that case. Maybe maybe that gets there. But if
you're making like 100k
that's not upper middle class.
>> As former chief of staff Miles H. There's a list and
he has been transparent. In fact, 5 days before the indictment
of James Comey,
he put this post up as instructions to you. He didn't mince words.
He was very open and public that you should indict James Comey
and others because they are guilty as hell.
No more delay. Now, 5 days before you
indicted
or grand jury at your instructions indicted James Comey,
I'd like to know from you what conversations you've had with
President
>> Well, I can't actually discuss private conversations
even though this is like the House Judic or it is a it's the
Senate Judiciary Committee, right? I think but it's like I can't
answer any questions of the things you're actually trying to
do oversight on >> about the indictment of James. >> Senator
Senator I am not going to discuss any conversations I have or
have not had with the president of the United States. You're
you're an attorney. You have a law degree and you know that I'm
not going to do that. I also find it fascinating, you know, because
>> I'll keep fighting to ensure that law enforcement and
the judicial process move forward without political interference.
No one is above the law. Not even the president. That's a quote
from you, Senator Blumenthal,
in 2017. >> Let me ask you then.
When you saw that, >> no one is above the law. That was
your >> When you saw that post, did you talk to anybody
in the White House?
>> I am not going to discuss in >> Dude, you know
you know for a fact that she she can't speak here. Do you know
why, right? Cuz at some point Trump's going to go and start talking
to the press and he's going to, "Yeah, I told Pam Bonnie you
got to go right now and indict this guy before the statute of
limit." He's just gonna literally say exactly how corrupt they
are. So, she can't lie here. She just has to say, "I can't answer
anything." And hope she can make it out alive someday. Cuz Trump
will 100% go and say, "Yeah, know I told Pam Bondi she has to
prosecute this."
>> he does it every time. >> Any conversations I
have nor any investigations, you are unwilling to tell this committee
about conversations with the White House. And if I may continue
indictment. >> And if I may continue, >> show you
a picture. >> James Comey was indicted
>> by one of the most liberal grand juries in the United
States. >> Oh, she said it again. >> The night before
James Comey's indictment. You had dinner with President United.
>> Are you telling me that Trump had the presence of mind
and the self-control to not bring up the possible indictment
of James Comey when you're sitting here at dinner with him the
night before Comey was indicted? Is that what you're telling
me,
>> Ms. bonding. >> Pretty intimate group. >> Actually,
there were a lot of people there that night. That's a great picture
discussed at that dinner. >> I love that picture. That's
a great picture. And there were a lot of people there that night.
I think the entire cabinet was there. >> Did you discuss
James Comey with the president of the United States? He was sitting
just to your left. >> Well, two seats down. Yes. Two seats
down. And I am not going to discuss
>> uh you didn't Oh, I guess I'm that way.
>> This is This is funny. Okay. cuz I feel like this is
she's debating how someone debates on the internet when they
know they're wrong. Right. It's like, "Ma'am, I believe you committed
an act of corruption by and and and like a gross norm violation
by discussing possible prosecutions with the president of the
United States who's sitting to your left." And she's like, "Well,
actually, he's sitting two seats to my left." And I want to talk
about how you're lying because it's obviously two seats to my
left. The evidence is right there and you're lying about it.
Okay? You just said he was sitting on my left and it's frankly
disgusting that you would say he's sitting on my left when he's
clearly sitting two seats to my left. It's like, oh dude, actually,
you know, if you've ever done online debate of any kind, that's
exactly how people act
or not have >> because the American public is entitled
to know Madam Attorney General, >> the entire took instructions
from President Trump after he told you very directly to indict
James Comey, which is weaponization of the Department of Justice.
I I want to agree with my colleague Senator Holly that weaponization
of our justice system must end. That's the reason that I propose
legislation and I challenge him and my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle to join me in legislation that would create
a statutory right of action for people who are selectively or
maliciously prosecuted for political reasons. It would codify
your manual, the Department of Justice manual
on political
prohibitions against political considerations in charging decisions
and prohibit the White House from intervening,
President Trump and any other president from intervening in political
in charging decisions. It would make reforms to the grand jury
process. You've just said this grand jury was liberal. We should
reform the grand jury process to ensure that the government is
not abusing its power and authority and will require transparency
and accountability reforms at EOJ so that you will and other
attorneys general be held accountable for these kinds of decisions.
Will you join me in supporting that kind of reform? >> Senator
Blumenthal, I find it so interesting that you didn't bring any
of this up during President Biden's administration when he was
doing everything to protect Hunter Biden, his son. And I think
you just saw what director Radcliffe just releas >> I actually
think he did nothing to protect Hunter except the pardon. I think
he literally stood out of the way of the Hunter thing. Now you
could say that's another form of corruption and disgusting. And
I might even agree with you on that. But the whole point of Hunter
Biden getting charged is that clearly Joe Biden stood out of
the way and let it happen. Like he literally backed the off let
them do whatever they want and they found him guilty. He's like
pardon. We're pardoning that guy. The Biden
isn't comparable because Joe Biden actually stuck to the norms.
And unfortunately for all of us, he he did the you do have to
acknowledge that he undermined the norms significantly by pardoning
his son because he explained how important it was for him to
not be involved, for him to respect the independent judiciary,
for him to respect the independent department of justice. Right.
and pardoning his son after standing on that soapbox is incredibly
like hypocritical. Like you you did not respect it. You're just
putting on a face so that you could say that, right? You're just
putting on this face so you could say it and and like virtue
signal and that you totally made you totally did something that
cuts against that in every possible way. It's it's pretty up
that he did that to be honest with you. Uh in a political sense
I understand why he did it, right? He's an old He's probably
got dementia of some kind. And why is he going to let his only
son go to prison over things that normally we get you a slap
on the wrist from the government, right?
That's that's I understand why he did it, but it is still corrupt.
Yeah. It It sucks cuz I at least I understand on that level.
I understand that's like a human thing, right? Yeah. It's your
son. It's It's your son. It's a human thing. Trump is violating
norms to enrich himself to make more money when he's already
bordering on a billionaire from his real estate in New York.
That is inhuman. That is like completely inhy
if I can finish answering the question. I'm not going to yell
over you. I'm not going to get in the gutter with you, but
>> information that the Biden administration told them
not to investigate Hunter Biden's involvement with Ukraine. And
I'm not going to be lectured to you about integrity. Another
topic will review lied about being in the military just to be
elected as
>> The merger between
Hulip Packet Enterprises and Juniper Network
was settled. You authorized the
It was the subject of a lawsuit to block it. The settlement produced
virtually no concessions from Packard. It was a settlement that
prompted me. >> As I stated earlier, Gail Slater is doing
an incredible job running the antitrust unit. And as I stated
earlier, that is still a pending matter. As you should know with
the lawyer at all mergers, if I can finish answering the >> I'm
going to finish. No, I'm answering the question. >> My
time is limit. >> Well, then don't ask me a question.
>> So, let me just ask you, >> as I said, you have
a law degree. you know that not only are mergers agreed upon,
but they have to go to a court of law to be approved. It's a
multi-step process. And as I said earlier, that is still pending.
And I have full faith in Gail Slater.
>> Um, I want to look into this cuz I have a feeling it's
probably something that the attorney general has a lot of purview
over, right?
Like approving or disapproving of mergers. I'm guessing they
do a lot. >> And Miss Slater reportedly objected. >> She's
making she's making it sound like she has nothing to do with
that. did do
>> Oh, here's an important tidbit then. Well, yeah, the
the judge actually said she doesn't want that happening, right?
>> Oh, so why why would she? Apparently, she could just
do whatever she wants. >> And moreover,
>> uh Well, so you're saying it's up to her, but she reportedly
said no. She reportedly like didn't want it. And moreover, moreover,
more nerd.
Mr. Senator Blumenthal, you're a nerd. Who says more over >> top
officials were fired? Roger Alfred and Bill Jenner. Did you authorize
and direct those firings after they objected to the settlement?
>> I am not going to discuss personnel matters or pending
litigation in my >> but you'll defer to the pending the
I guess the judge and say what that you disagree with her statements
that she's made like allegedly and you won't answer anything
about corruption. Just any of their things that people are alleging
are corrupt they can't talk about guys. Turns out we can't we
can't do it. Let me ask you about another merger. Oh, >> give
me two uh merger involving
paramount guidance. >> Two home healthcare agencies on
favorable terms likely to drive up costs for millions of America.
The transportation department's rule to provide compensation
to travelers impacted by airline caused flight delays which was
cancelled. the merger of Sky
>> and Paramount after Paramount's ownership took a number
of steps
favorable to the president. these kinds of mergers bely the claims
that that President Trump himself has made, that
this administration will stop big corporate mergers that ultimately
benefit
the owners of those corporations rather than consumers or ordinary
everyday Americans. Senator, let me ask you, you just listed
you just gave a list of of many mergers. Can you talk to me about
the the issue with these mergers? I I do have a question in the
merger
that took place. >> Oh [__] Uh she's trying
to say uh excuse me. What's your problem with any of that? I
hope he's got he should have stuff written down for this cuz
there are problems. >> Which merger you've listed >> involving
American Express GB? I understand that Brian Ballard
>> longtime backer and
>> here's the thing. Okay.
The the Ellison connection is the easiest thing to point to with
regards to the corruption going on here and the you go Ellison
connection paramount skydance to the Tik Tok purchase. Okay.
And none of them are going to bring it up and I don't know why.
>> Head of the law firm where you work was
>> Just kidding. I feel like I know why. >> In lobbying
the Justice Department to drop that lawsuit. It was dismissed.
So it's not subject to a court review. What conversations did
you have with Mr.
>> Senator Blumenthal, I Rick, I cannot believe that you
would accuse me of impropriety when you lied about your military
service.
>> Did she just call him Senator Ballard?
>> Did I Did I totally misear that? >> Senator Blumenthal,
I I cannot believe >> How did the Hold on. >> that
you would accuse me. >> How the did I hear Ballard there?
What? What is going on with my brain?
>> Of impropriy when you lied about your military service.
You lied. You admitted you lied to be elected a US senator. You
lied. How dare you? I'm a career prosecutor. Don't you ever challenge
my integrity. I have abided by every ethics standard. Do not
question my ability to be fair and impartial as attorney general
and anything. My former firm valored partners. >> Thank
you.
Uh, Senator uh, Lee has asked for the chair just wanted to note
for the record the Paramount merger that he referenced was not
within the Department of Justice's am but that that was uh, at
the FCC, not the Department of Justice. Attorney General Bonnie
would have had nothing to do with that. Thanks. >> And
that was why >> Oh, that's fair. I I knew that actually.
I knew that it was Brandon Carr who had oversight on that one.
>> I asked Senator Lee. He didn't know that. He was reading
off a script. >> Before I call on Senator Kennedy, uh,
it's kind of laughable about my Democrats friends uh, expressing
fear. Obama Obama Democrats. Obama Democrat. Dude, this guy is
like the crypt keeper. This guy, how old did we find out this
guy was? Wasn't he like 93 or something? Chuck Grassley.
He is 92.
92 years old. Holy [__]
This guy's This guy's getting up there.
>> Why not? Senator Herano. >> Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
>> Herano. Sorry, not but Herano. FISA section 702 will
expire in 6 months. In response to response to my questions for
the record uh at your confirmation hearing, you said you did
not have experience with FISA, but if confirmed you would consult
with experts at DOJ. Now you've had that opportunity. Do you
support adding additional safeguards for searching Americans
communications in the 702 database?
Senators, section 702 is a vital source of foreign intelligence
and instrumental
in keeping Americans safe. We also take individuals rights of
American their individual rights of all Americans very
>> Uh it's it's cool that you know I do appreciate this
cuz obviously there's going to be things you want to grill Pam
Bondi over for political reasons, for political theater. That
is what most committee hearings are like when you have somebody
coming in it's it's grilling them for political theater. I always
like the people who will have like a relevant question first
and then yeah it is a no. I always like the people who have a
relevant question first that they're like trying to still get
their job done and then they're like okay now it's time for political
theater >> and many statutory reforms to FISA have incorporate
safeguards. They have to incorporate safeguards to protect our
civil liberties. The Department of Justice looks forward to working
with
>> to discuss anything regarding 702. I
we new angle on the collar. Let's take a look. Me a link.
Let's see. Let's see. Uhoh.
Mr. Hassan [__]
with the with the big ka zoomin. Okay, we've got another shot
at the same collar.
When is this from? This is from 6 months ago. Oh.
Oh.
Okay.
That does look like one of those Air Tag things a little bit.
Okay, that looks like one of the Air Tag things. And then I don't
know. I mean, that's still just a big black block that's sitting
there,
Oh, even even when she comes over like this, it still looks like
more. You still got the the big green box. Sorry, the big black
box with the green light on it.
>> I don't know that I get more information out of this
one.
I feel like I feel like this is 100% the Air Tag thing. This
is six months ago.
This is the air tag thing. 100% right.
And then I don't know what the black box kind of dog is. Is that
a Tibetan mastiff and some other stuff? Bernie's mountain dog.
Uh that might be true.
>> She's literally larger than me.
Oh. Oh. How does she get closer like that? Oh, we got to change
up any
better than
>> We got one more angle here. >> I don't even think
she wants to, >> man. I don't know. I don't know. I feel
it's probably some kind of disciplinary caller or or a uh like
what? A geofencing caller. Either way, >> that's the problem.
She just wants to
like I'm letting her go up to four.
But she like just wants to see. >> It's kind of hard to
keep her staying up like this because she's 120 lb. You know
what I mean? Hard to keep.
>> Got we got this guy like this. Another one. Okay. All
right.
Is that supposed to be a bad thing? The shot color. It wouldn't
be a bad thing if it weren't for how Hassan used it today. If
he used the shot color the way he used it today. Uh
I not good. Not great. Okay. To be like annoyed with your dog
and then you use it to display. I feel like it's not a shot caller.
Shel, why did you go Okay. You You just follow You just had two
statements. You're like, "Oh, a shot color wouldn't even do anything
to a child." And then you're like, "It's not a shot color." Which
which is it? Why you doing multiple defenses at the same time?
>> Keep her staying up like this because she's 120 lb.
You know what I mean? >> Okay. She's done. She's like,
I'm done. >> I don't know if we get anything new out of
that. It is It is cool to see the new
but I feel like I'm seeing all the same stuff I was seeing before.
More or less.
hold on. Is this real? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Back to back to
Pam Bondi real quick. There's no way this is real.
Reuters photographer Jonathan Erns noticed that Bondi flipped
open a file during the Senate hearing and zoomed in. Inside were
her [__] notes for attacking the senators. The GOP
now practicing cliffnotes fascism. In other words, under oath,
Bondi was purely a per something. White House
I asked how something I can't read it that well.
Oh, Sheldon White House. This is Oh, this is Sheldon White House.
I was like, oh, something something white. But it's Senator White
House. It's She's got She's got her hit piece on Senator White
House sitting right here.
I Aren't you just allowed to have a laptop? Why didn't you just
take a laptop? Why' you spend all your time just like figuring
out how you're going to grill these people?
Goofy.
Oh, Shel White House. You claim to be a social justice warrior,
but you're a member of you rail against dark money, but you work
with dark money groups. You talk about Oh, she said this. She's
like, correct me if I'm wrong, but you work with dark money groups.
Her citation a little a little uh cliff note. Okay. You ra against
dark money, but you work with dark money
Bruh, you are a total hypocrite. Underline. You talk about corruption,
but you push for legislation that would underline. So, I don't
even know. Bruh,
I asked about or freaking I'll tell you a personnel issue that
I'm having are dude. She wrote down all of her [__]
I'm telling you, a personal issue that I'm having is that I can't
pay my my lawyers. I can't pay my attorneys. I can't pay anybody
because Democrats shut down. No government official should be
above the law. The American people deserve a comprehensive investig
investigation into the potential violations of ethics and tax
laws by Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas.
Kiss the boss's app. Cover mine.
Oh, it's just put in there. I see.
Okay.
I feel like there's still a chance that that's like maybe photoshopped,
but I don't think it is. I don't think it is. That seems like
it could easily be cuz she said all of these things
They're going after Thomas. This would have been back when you
found out that Tom uh Thomas's wife had what was it? A flag.
She had some kind of flag.
And then you found out that Thomas was taking gifts from that
billionaire, going on trips with him. And this would have been
at that time, I assume. Hold There's probably a date on the tweet.
Yeah. July 20. I forget what Thomas had that his his wife did
something and they were like going at him pretty hard for
We should put the flag upside down. Was it a flag upside down?
I Okay. Anyway,
I think we we're moving on from Kaia the Ka update. We're going
to move over back to
our testimony from Pam Bondi.
No, Max. I'm good. But thank you for being here, Max. Thank you
for showing your support. Guys, we are
what are we one sub away from two more hours on the stream. Let's
get that one sub in. Get those two more hours in the stream.
>> I believe my staff and and Senator, I also want to thank
you for for this hearing. Your staff met with my staff and I
greatly appreciate that. >> Oh, the flag thing might have
been >> We're going to be working on 702. So, I appreciate
the openness to further uh amending 702. At your confirmation
hearing, you assured me that it is a Department of Justice's
decision to determine what cases will be prosecuted. last month
in the US at the US attorney for the Eastern District of Virginia
was forced out. President Trump then posted the message behind
me asking uh about prosecuting James Comey. You then appointed
a new US attorney who within days secured an indictment against
James Comey.
That social media post behind me saying, "What about Comey?"
was directed to Pam. Are you the Pam that the
>> Wait, which which Pam was he talking about? Hold up.
He said Pam. I kind of assumed it was you. Is there a different
Pam in the Justice Department?
>> James Comey.
>> That social media post behind me saying, "What about
Comey?" was directed to Pam. Are you the Pam that the president
was referring to?
>> By the way, are you are you that Pam? Pam. By the way,
this is where they speculated that Trump was direct trying to
direct message Pam Bondi or something and like had a dementia
moment because what the going on here that he goes Pam and then
it just continues.
What the happened? Why would you? >> I'm sure I was. >> So,
it's very clear to me that when the president posts something
like that that he considers the DOJ to be his law firm and you
his lawyer. And in fact, very shortly after the post to you,
uh, Comey gets indicted.
Last year, President Trump's new borders are now border Tom Hman
was videotape taking a bag with $50,000 in cash from undercover
FBI. A >> Okay, this woman won. Why is this woman the coolest
senator? I didn't even know how to pronounce her name at first.
I didn't even know how to pronounce her name. And she's like
the coolest senator
Dude, Tom Hman. Tom, I didn't even realize Tom Hman looked like
Mr. like uh Mr. Bunny Bags or whatever the is it Moneybags Henningsworth?
I can't >> Suggesting he could help with government contract.
Sounds like a bribe. Two weeks ago, did DOJ officials reportly
shut down the bribery investigation into Mr. Holman? Miss Bondi,
did you >> Noburn penny bags >> approve
closing the Homeman investigation? Bribery investigation.
Senator Herono, as I stated earlier,
Department of Justice and the FBI
conducted a thorough review and they found no credible evidence
of any wrongdoing. You were also on video outside the White House
protesting with a group called CASSA where Antifa members were.
Does that mean you're a member of Antifa? >> You know,
I simply
>> Wait, which folder? Hold on. and she opened a folder
ready
conducted a thorough review and they found no credible evidence
of any wrongdoing. You were also on video outside the White House
protesting with a group called CASSA where Antifa members were.
Does that mean you're a member of Antifa? >> You know,
I simply asked the question as to whether or not you approved
the shutting down of the investigation. Mr. Holman, I have to
assume that you did because the FBI it reports to you. But the
American people would look at the situation where this person
is taking a 50,000 $50,000 in cash. >> She is looking down
>> cash no less. And that you testified today that a thorough
investigation was done. Now I have to assume I conclude that
since no wrongdoing was determined that in answer to Senator
White House's question, he kept the money. He kept the money
and I hope that he put that on his tax returns as income.
Next question. Over,200 riers were convicted of charges related
to January 6th. President Trump has since pardoned nearly all
of them. As if that weren't enough, last month there was there
were reports that a lawyer for the January 6 riers met with senior
DOJ officials about setting up a compensation fund. a compensation
fund like the one that Congress set up after 911 to comp >> Bro,
do you remember how hard Jonathan Stu John Stewart the the commentator
the the comedian? Do you remember how hard he had to fight to
get the money for the firefighters? How he was going to Congress
every time they ever had a hearing on this?
Could you imagine
the the wrath of the speech that would come if they decided they
were going to pass a compensation fund for January 6th riers?
Oh my god. I think he might Dude, I I'm just going to say for
his own good, okay, somebody needs to start tracking that guy's
purchases cuz I'm worried that he's going to do something drastic
at that point. All right. I think whatever caused that guy to
crack and go to retirement and then he came back with like the
beard looks like he was in the cabin like the Ted Kazinski cabin.
He's going to be back in that cabin the second he hears that
news. >> Compensate these riers. Miss Bondi, is anyone
at DOJ
considering setting up a compensation fund for January 6 riers?
Yes or no?
>> Senator, I have had no meetings or discussions about
a fund. >> So would you support such a fund? Would would
you okay such a fund? >> Senator, you can send me the information
on the fund and I'd be happy to look at >> No, but do you
think that's a good idea to you? This is what I'm getting at
because to actually set up a fund and to have people talking
with your senior people at DOJ, political people about creating
a fund and you won't uh let us know what you think about that.
I that's pretty unbelievable.
On January 30th of this year, the Trump DOJ's Anit trust division
sued to block the merger of two tech companies.
Then a well-connected lobbyist met with your political deputies
who overruled the career staff and approved >> this is
the HP merger again >> approved the merger. So there's
a settlement on that and separately DOJ sued ticket master last
year for monopolizing concert tickets and forcing consumers to
pay outrageous fees. Ticket Master has hired the exact same lobbyists
who met with senior DOJ political people regarding the merger
of the two tech companies. So um my question is Miss Bondi, have
lobbyists met with your political deputies about the ticket Master
case.
Senator Herono, as I stated earlier, I am not going to discuss
anything that is ongoing. Gail Slater runs the antitrust.
>> I would say and Gail Slater, if I can finish, Gail Slater
is doing an incredible job running my antitrust >> It's
highly likely, Miss Bondi, that the same lobbyist who met with
your people basically got rid of the antitrust uh uh >> Senator,
I don't think a lot of people like that you were out protesting
with Antifa right now. >> Um yeah, we're we're doing all
kinds of corruption. Uh Antifa, Antifa, you are Antifa. Antifa,
everybody. She This [__] is Antifa. Do not pay attention
to the corruption. This this Asian woman is Antifa. Look at her.
You can tell she throws Molotov.
You have fired dozens of career. >> It It doesn't hit quite
so well to paint this like elderly Asian lady as a radical. Does
it like I'm sorry. This looks like she's going to bake some cookies
and and bring them to like a protest. I don't know what we're
what are we trying to do here? prosecutors because they worked
on cases involving President Trump for January 6 riers. For example,
one career federal prosecutor secured who secured over 100 convictions
in Florida. He also spent time in DC prosecuting January 6 cases.
He received an outstanding review only two days before you signed
a memo firing him. The memo cited no reason for his firing. Are
you firing career prosecutors solely because they worked on cases
like January 6th that the president doesn't >> Senator
Herono, I am not going to talk about personnel matters with you.
>> Well, we all know that hundreds of career prosecutors
have left the DOJ and uh uh literally hundreds were told. Um
>> yeah, Senator, are you familiar with the one that threw
a sandwich at a at a at an ICE officer? Are you a homeland security
officer? I think
>> that's tip five. >> Oh, hold on.
>> U Y Y Y J J J J S T K Put it there then
J HD
them
>> Oh, this broke for you. Hold on. I'll try I'll try my
best. >> In good faith, I will honor that donation. I will
try to to hit it for you. Okay. Hey, JST go the damn yink this
batty off the screen. Bronto. Holy [__] Zoe. She
mega spicy hot. Goddamn pow. Chiron president.
Wowza. Okay, I'm I did my best to honor the donation. Okay, I
did my I That's about what he wrote. Okay, I'm not I didn't even
do the pronunciation. He wrote down the
All right, it wasn't even me.
Okay, hold on. Uh, that also adds two more hours to the stream.
Let's go.
Let's go. 25150.
Thank you very much. Uh Xi Jinping assistant. Is that was that
the Xi Jinping official? Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Oh, you're with the one who went out on her lunch break
and was taking off >> Would you say that DOJ losing these?
>> Oh, is is XQC going off about Stale? XQC is not happy
with Stale doing some sweeping for Hassan.
Give me a second. Give me a second. Why can't I pull this up?
>> Okay, we'll finish
>> We'll finish thing then I'll pull that >> And
the thousands of hours of experience they have prosecuting criminals.
That is not a reassuring situation.
>> Senator, many employees took the fork in the road and
resigned. DOJ is hiring committed prosecutors who will actually
come into the office and work and not work remotely and prosecute
violent criminals around the country and terrorists. And I'm
very proud of the work all of our all of our prosecutor. I'm
running out of time. So I think you should stop with your continuous
interruptions. In my opinion, Mr. Chairman, I just want to close
by saying that what was once the Department of Justice has become
the Department of Revenge and Corruption. Rather than pursuing
cases without fear or favor, this DOJ seeks to favor the president's
friends and instill fear in his alleged enemies. If you're a
friend of the president, this corrupt DOJ will bend over backwards
to help you just like it. If you're a friend of the press, they'll
they'll straight up pardon you. >> It dropped the bribery
investigation of Tom Pullman like it's considering paying money
to January 6 riers and like it has put antirust enforcement decisions
in the hands of well-connected lobbyists. But if you're on the
wrong side of this president, you will face the wrath of DOJ
no matter what the facts, law, or justice support. James Comey
is indicted days after the president social media directive.
Experienced career prosecutors are fired just because they were
assigned to work on January 6 cases. Blue states are sued to
get highly sensitive private voter data, whereas red states are
left alone. The double standard is clear and the American people
are waking up to the corruption and favoritism and the lawlessness
at the DOJ. Thank you, Mr. >> May I respond, chairman?
>> Yes. Question. >> May I respond? >> Yes,
you you may. >> Um, Antifa, that's all. >> And then
Senator Kennedy, >> thank you. The double standard is crystal
clear, Senator Herono. Crystal clear. Because
>> you didn't complain for four years when President Trump
was being targeted by Jack Smith by the last Justice Department,
but the American people spoke loud and clear when they overwhelmingly
elected him. The two-tier system of justice is over. >> Senator
Kennedy.
>> Okay. I'm sorry. Was there was there something where
the federal government prosecuted Trump for something he didn't
do or or failed to prosecute him for or failed to prosecute somebody
else for bribery in the same way? Like just open on there bribery.
Yeah, we're not watching Kennedy. Don't worry. We're not watching
this one. We've got a couple more yet to go. Okay, we've got
a couple more uh we want to do I think I'm skipping Booker. I
don't care about Booker. Uh he doesn't talk about any of the
stuff I Well, sorry. I actually usually like Cory Booker, like
listening to him because he so out, but uh he actually he sticks
mostly to
either stuff in his state or
immigration stuff. And I'm I'm more interested in DOJ independence.
So,
>> hold up Padilla next. >> Appreciate
the opportunity to uh participate in this hearing today, which
is our at minimum annual opportunity.
>> Oh, wait, wait, wait. Before we hold on before we get
to Mr. Padilla here. I was going to check out this tweet from
Riyle. It's a new Oct tweet. Give me a second.
We got some stuff. See here.
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Let's see. XC mad about LSF mods taking
down threats.
>> I actually think the same thing. Okay, it's it's
not even it's just like totally it's like total content death
for some reason. They just don't want their subreddit to be active
or be talking about anything.
remove a moderator.
Oh, not this again.
Not this again. I
>> like, trust me, I don't even think Listen, this is like
totally
This is What would you say? This is like a
This is really bad for Hassan, right? Like I I have no reason
to like support
I have no reason in particular to like support this being taken
down or staying up, but I just want the content, man. I just
want content. That's all I want. Why are you Why are you stopping
your subreddit from being a piece a like piece in the arsenal
of every streamer? Like, every streamer will use this subreddit,
will review parts of the subreddit. It's what made your subreddit
grow and be useful. And you're just trying to consistently force
everybody to go over to a or somewhere else because you suck.
Come on, bro.
Come on, bro. Again.
Yo. Yo, LSF mods. Yo, you have me on Discord. Give me Give me
a ring. Yo, I I know you might be watching, buddy. Give me a
ring. I had you on stream last time. Buddy, explain. Explain.
I said last time you guys are doing better. And if you guys do
this, I will hell hold you accountable. I have to hold you guys
accountable.
I have to.
Is XQC going to yell at Stale? Let's go.
>> Stale's going to be like, "No, no, no. You You You don't
understand XQC. You don't No, no. just I I most people don't
understand this, but what I have to do is I have to all the content
on on this because I I don't want it to be a toxic place. I just
don't want it to be toxic. I want it to be like a friendly place
for everybody and and I think you just don't get that. I think
I think you you you know I just want things to be accurate. That's
all. That's all. I just want things to be accurate and I the
big thing the big one is I don't want Reddit to ban us. Okay,
you don't have no idea how Reddit happens. They get rid of the
subreddit and then I don't have anything. Okay, I just want this
to be a place for like gaming news and fun clips. Okay, I just
want to be fun clips. I went to a Discord recently and I asked
them to post their clips cuz I just want fun clips. Okay, so
I just I want you guys to understand where I'm coming from and
I just want like fun
clips on my subreddit.
>> Come on, bro. >> Oh, thank you. Thank you, Stale.
Thank you for that interview with FQC. >> Guys, what was
the name again? I forgot. I I remove my moderator. >> Damn.
Okay.
Anyway,
moving on back to Pam Bondi and Mr. Padilla. Mr. Padilla Padilla
>> today, which is our at minimum annual
uh to >> we go from mocking stale to once again putting
on our serious caps and contemplating
the death of DOJ and and
the death of DOJ independence, okay? and how it is for the country
for your country. Okay. >> Ask questions as we fulfill
our obligation to provide accountability over the Department
of Justice. So, just sort of to level set a little bit for folks
in the audience and for folks watching at home, the Department
of Justice is supposed to be the nation's guardian of fairness
and the rule of
The power of the Department of Justice is built on public trust
and a belief that prosecutions are based on facts >> and
law, not on >> um sir, I think you can't possibly criticize
me because you didn't accuse the the previous administration
of of bias or corruption. So you can't criticize me >> politics
or personal loyalty. And I call that out, Mr. Because when that
breaks down, when the public trust breaks down,
then justice itself is at risk.
But under this Trump administration and the leadership of Attorney
General Bondi, I believe the independence of the Department of
Justice has come under attack. The department has been reorganized.
It's been realigned and repurposed in ways that we've never seen
before. Important offices have been closed, key programs dismantled,
and agents diverted. All without congressional authorization
or transparent
justification. Now, these are not minor bureaucratic changes.
They represent a fundamental shift in the Department of Justice's
missions and priorities, its policies.
>> I really don't like >> it just be your pig.
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Stale won't do [__]
He'll need hair on his balls for that which he probably had transplanted
to his head.
>> Jesus Christ. Thank you, Reuben. Ruben. Jesus. And it's
practice. >> I hate when senators do this, by the way.
When they when they do this whole grand standing thing instead
of just start asking the questions, okay? Interact with the other
person. This isn't a soapbox moment. It is an interactive moment.
You're supposed to interact with the person you have in the Senate
chamber or in the whatever House Judiciary Chamber. House Judiciary.
Yeah. House, right? >> For example, career prosecutors
have been put to change decisions in politically sensitive cases.
>> Yeah. Senate judiciary oversight has been taken away
from independent career professionals and handed to political
appointees with little experience in these matters. Internal
working groups have been created to revisit investigations involving
President Trump and his allies.
And together, these steps send a dangerous message that prosecutorial
decisions
>> Okay. Uh, sorry. opting out of you. You are doing a
horrible job
after after Herano. Okay, he's just kind of getting totally outclassed
by Herano. So, oh, okay, hold on. Somebody points out the inconsistency.
This next guy >> points out the inconsistency. >> Senator
Schmidt, Senator Welch. >> Uh, thank you. Thank you. >> He's
going to point out how she will talk about pending litigation.
>> To uh Attorney General Bondi. Um I have noticed that
at various times when one of our my colleagues is pressing you
you >> let her do her first response to Padilla. Okay,
hold on. First response to Padilla swaying out of everything.
>> Appreciate uh the agents diverted all without congressional
authorization or transparent justice. Now these are not minor
bureaucratic changes. They represent a fundamental shift in the
Department of Justice's missions and priorities, its policies,
and its practices. For example, career prosecutors have been
pressured to change decisions in politically sensitive cases.
Ethics oversight has been taken away from independent career
professionals and handed to political appointees with little
experience in these matters. >> Internal working groups
have been created to revisit involving President Trump and his
allies. And together, these steps send a dangerous message that
prosecutorial decisions can be driven by political loyalty instead
of the law. Now, even more troubling is that the Department of
Justice has pulled resources away from organized crime, away
from counterterrorism, away from uh the uh protection of civil
rights, to focus on immigration enforcement. The American people
expect a Department of Justice to pursue violent crime, as do
I, to pursue corruption and threats to national security. The
corruption thing is just the craziest part that they go and they
gut their entire corruption department >> not to serve
as an arm of immigration policy and in so doing underresource
other critical missions. Now the justice department's credibility
depends on the public's faith in justice and that the justice
will be applied equally to every person and not reserved for
the powerful or the connected and that faith must be protected.
And so it's in that spirit that this committee has a duty to
ensure the department's work remains lawful, remains transparent,
and remains true to its highest duty, the fair and impartial
administration of justice. Now, that being said, I do want to
get into some specific items um with Attorney General Bondi here,
beginning with the firing of Michelle Beckwith. Michelle Beckwith
was a 15-year career prosecutor with the Department of Justice.
She prosecuted in her career some of the worst of the worst in
my home state of California. Sex traffickers, transnational terrorists,
those who this administration claims to care about and be targeting,
prioritizing and taking them off the streets. >> And it
may surprise some to learn that Miss Beckwith was unceremony
marched out of her office and fired from her job in July of this
year. >> Why not because she failed to do her job? Quite
the opposite. It was because she had the audacity to remind Border
Patrol Chief Gregory Bino that he was obligated to follow a court
order and the Constitution in California. According to reports,
she was fired less than 6 hours after she told Bino he couldn't
arrest people without probable cause. 6 hours. So my first question,
Attorney General Bondi, is a simple yes no question. Do you believe
that government officials like Gregor Bino are obligated to follow
applicable court orders whether they agree with them or not?
Yes or no?
I mean, she's definitely not going to answer yes or no, but let's
see. >> First, Senator Padilla, you have gone on for over
five minutes, and I wish that you loved your state of California
as much as you hate President Trump. We'd be in really good shape
then because
>> crime in California is currently >> He did yap.
Unfortunately, handing Pam Pam Bondi her only W of this entire
hearing. Okay, this just yapped about like just dude, get to
your questions. start pointing out her inconsistencies. Don't
just get on a soap box is stupid. There's literally no reason.
You got Twitter, you have the media, you can do >> 35%
higher than the national average. Property crime in California
is 18% higher than the national average. That should be something
that we should be talking about and working together on. Yet,
we're not. No, this is important. You're talking about all these
all of my agencies and I want I want to let you know what DEA
has been doing and they are working hand in hand. I appreciate
that. No, you can't go on for 5 minutes and criticize my agents
who are out working without pay right now because you voted to
shut down the government. They're out there working without pay.
>> Mr. Chairman, I asked a simple yes or no question. Uh
trans bond 4500 kilos of 50 million fentanyl pills off the streets
23,000 violent criminals. US
>> I'm trying to Dude, why do you have a chairman who's
93? He does not know what's happening. He is being controlled
by a mouse on top of his head. Okay. It's weekend at Bernie's.
Every single day, Chuck Grassley shows up to the hill. I'm >> I'm
not getting answer to my question. I'm trying to move on to the
next question or the next topic. >> Mr. Chairman, order,
please. Thank you.
ridiculous. Ridiculous.
Okay, we've got come up with something in their background. Uh,
so I'll be waiting for my turn,
but you don't have to do it right now. So, let me >> Oh,
he's pointing out how like listen, I I know that you're going
to do some kind of like hip piece on me for no reason. >> Get
to my questions.
U one of the things that you mentioned, and I agree with this,
that it's really tough on the various federal uh federal workforce,
including our law enforcement folks. >> Okay. I want this
guy for the next question to shut down. >> I I agree with
that. Um, but I also think that wasn't the whole Vermont family.
Some blue states. Another topic.
>> there we go. There we go. >> Respective voting
rights in the letter that your voting rights uh chief sent out.
We got one in Vermont and it's a demand. There was an assertion
by the chief in this division that this was to deal with the
fact that the voting process has been taken over by the left.
So, we got one of those letters in Vermont. And my question to
you is, what do you mean by the left? And do you have any evidence
that the so-called system has been overtaken by the left? >> We
must have fair and free elections. >> No, no, I know that,
but I'm asking for the spec,
>> dude. He interrupted the robot. He interrupted. She
actually listened. Listen. Yeah. Nobody disagrees
>> obviously basis. >> And we will have fair and
free elections in this country.
>> Oh, she's continuing. >> Be happy to talk to my
chief. Who Who was it who said that? It was it was your chief
which I assume you would know who's who that is. Here here's
the question here. Okay. There is a point of view that is in
dispute here about the fairness of elections
and but you have the power as the US as the attorney general
to use the authority of your office to make demands on states
and you did that with Vermont. That's within your right to do
it. I'm not disputing your legal authority to do it. >> Is
Vermont disputing turning over the information to our office?
Vermont is the Secretary of State is, and you can resolve that
with her, but >> and we have every right to have that information.
Here's where I'm going. Why wouldn't they want to turn it? >> You're
a prosecutor with the awesome authority to make the decision
that you're going to start an investigation against the state
or against an individual. And I know from your experience as
a county prosecutor and as the attorney general in Florida, you
took seriously that obligation to have a factual basis before
you'd proceed.
>> Senator? I take that
role. I take my oath very seriously and I take fair and free
elections in this country very seriously and that information
are all >> so what is the factual basis for you requesting
that information what is your probable cause what is your probable
cause and tell me it's not a gut feeling because holy >> this
is entitled to have that information and we are involved in litigation
on that and I assume we'll be involved in litigation with Vermont
>> we have a Republican governor in Vermont we had our
former Republican governor uh was secretary was was a treasurer
for many years and also the secretary.
>> Oh, apparently this is for like voter roles to find
illegals, not necessarily to do with free and fair elections,
although that is the the assertion here >> with election
responsibility. What I'm asking is do you or does your uh head
of this voting section have any factual basis that you can point
to that justifies your demand that Vermont turn over all this
confidential voting rights information? Well, it would remain
confidential with my office and you just said that you have a
Republican governor. So, you're it doesn't make sense what you
just said. We've asked out of every state since
>> he didn't say you don't have the right to ask for it.
He said do you have a basis for asking for it? What do you want
it for? What are you doing? You know, the basis of like criminal
justice or or all legal decisions in your country like, "Hey,
I should have some idea. I shouldn't be on a fishing expedition.
I should have some idea of what I'm looking for, right? Do we
not have illegals can't vote? Yeah, it's something to do with
the the roles there having like you could be registered to vote
without valid citizenry. I I suppose, right? Like I I'm guessing
you would have like a fake social security. I have no idea, but
apparently there was some request for voter data voter data that
was supposed to show that illegals were voting, >> right?
And I'm asking about Vermont, what the factual basis is, but
we we can move on. the uh you know you've mentioned that you
can't discuss pending litigation and I think the committee by
and large accepted that answer but I did notice that you spoke
at great length about pending litigation specifically with respect
to the questions Senator Cruz asked you about the sentencing
of the Kavanaaugh defendant that's pending >> he was sentenced
to 8 years >> I understand that but that's on appeal >> we
will be appealing >> right so that makes it pending litigation
so you made an exception with respect to the cruise question
didn't answer any of the questions that you said were pending
at litigation from any of my colleagues. >> Those were
facts that came out at the sentencing hearing. You're welcome
to see the transcript of the sentencing hearing with all the
gruesome details of what they threatened to do to Justice Kavanaaugh
and other justice. >> I I condemn what that person did.
>> What was the sentencing? >> But the point here
is that that's pending litigation. You >> finally reporting
on it. Did you see the story about the woman Ice just shot in
cold blood? Nope. >> Indicate you're going to be appealing.
It's your right to do that and you would not you you use that
justification to not answer many other questions >> justification.
You're an attorney,
>> you realize that. >> I do want to go back to home
and you know there's
>> you're an attorney, Senator. It's like yeah, I'm an
attorney. I understand what the um
what being above a pro be with behy
beyond reproach means, right? like as as somebody who's an attorney,
who's somebody who deals with ethical questions, do you think
it's appropriate for the president of the United States to be
giving you directives about charging people the day before you
charge them, the day before you indict >> There's a tape,
right, with Mr. Hman? I mean, first of all, is there a tape and
that has audio and video of the transfer of the 50,000? >> You
would have to talk to Director Patel about that. >> No,
I I'm talking to you. >> I don't know the answer, Senator.
>> You do know the answer to that. >> I didn't call
you a liar. You just I know the answer. >> Hold on. Hold
on. >> You would have to talk to Director Patel about that.
>> No, I'm I I'm talking to you. >> I don't know
the answer. Senator, >> you do know the answer to that.
>> Don't call me a liar. >> I didn't call
>> Wait, you have to know the answer to that. Are you out
here saying, are you out here talking about this? You have no
idea what they have. You haven't asked anybody about it and you
understand that you're going to be asked this question multiple
times. What the does it say in that binder? You didn't think
we were going to ask you about this? >> Call you a >> Yeah,
exactly. It's like either you are the most incompetent attorney
general this country's ever had, which we can't even rule out,
or you know what I'm talking about. One of the two. >> You
just said I know the answer. I said I don't know the answer.
You have to talk to Director Vel. What I said is that investigation.
>> If you don't know, why don't you know whether there
was a tape and video?
>> Senator, I believe that was resolved prior to my confirmation
as attorney >> Do you think that it is of public Are you
you understand it's in the papers right now >> interest
for the people to know what happened to the 50 grand that the
FBI turned over to Homeman. >> Did you hear what I just
said? That was resolved prior to my confirmation as attorney
general. That's why I said I would not go first. >> It's
not resolved. There's $50,000.
Hman has it or somebody has it. Do you have no interest in knowing
where it is?
>> You're not going to sit here and
>> dude. Tom Hman slandered himself. He took $50,000 in
a grocery bag. Okay. It's not slander.
>> It's not slander. >> Um, the FBI and deputy director
of Lanch said there was nothing. >> I'm not slamming Tom
Hman. He got to 15. >> Tomman is doing How do you know
that Tom Hman is doing a great job as our borders are keeping
>> Why would that be relevant? Why would that be a fact
that actually Why would that be a fact that
that uh Oh, what am I looking for? That disincludes, disconnects.
Why would it be something that disproves, sorry, disproves whether
or not he took the money? He could be a great borders are and
be chopping women up in his basement. Being a great borders has
nothing to do with committing crime.
>> You're a border state safe. You're a border state. >> Thank
you, Senator Welch. We're going to >> President
Not right now. If you wait personal privilege, >> not right
now there, Senator Tis and many others have been waiting to turn.
>> I know
that relates to testimony that you gave about me. >> Senator
Tis, go ahead. >> Thank you, Madam Chair.
Okay,
more partisan theatrics, I guess. But jeez.
Okay, I'm looking for I think we go from here to what is it?
No, we just watched Welch. I think the last one we're watching
here is
Shifty Shiff himself. >> Thank you. >> All right,
we got Shifty Shiff himself and then we're going to go to the
CNN testimony. The CNN guy.
This guy. And then somebody linked me the inconsistencies
from Shifty Shift's testimony as well. So, we're probably going
to check out all of those things
and then we'll move on to our next topic. So, I'm cleaning up
tabs here.
back. Thank you, >> Senator Tillis. Senator Schiff. >> Uh,
thank you, Madam Chair. Attorney General Bondi at your confiration
hearing in January made a clear commitment you would not politicize
your
>> We're here today. First over. >> Wait. Oh, hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. He did just start. Wait. Was Welch is in
Vermont. I didn't even realize that she was yelling you're a
border state. He's talking about Canadians.
You're a border state, sir. You're a border state. You should
respect the borders are >> sight hearing nine months into
your tenure at a time when hundreds of career prosecutors have
quit because they were required to take unethical actions at
odds with that promise or fear that they would have >> you
have no idea how effective you guys could be with the northern
border propaganda if you started trying to paint it. Okay, Republicans
little little nugget for you. If you started painting it is like
Canadians are people are coming through Canada and using the
Canadian border Indians to enter the US illegally. If you started
doing that, okay, you guys would win. You guys, you guys could
get that border shut down. >> Have to take such actions
if they remained on the job. When over a thousand former federal
prosecutors have sounded the alarm about the unprecedented degree
to which the powers of DOJ are being abused to go after the president's
enemies.
I approached this hearing with a heavy heart. As a former federal
prosecutor myself, I served in a department that whether it was
under a Democratic or Republican president, would never use the
office to go after the president's enemies or to hide the corruption
of his friends.
But today, the Justice Department has been used to cover up the
possible corruption of the mayor of New York or of a high level
administration official taking $50,000
>> Yeah.
In cash in a bag. >> These are the two big ones. child
predator who befriended the president and some of his cabinet
members.
>> wait, is that talking about the the the mega church
pastor that got arrested? Trump's spiritual adviser. >> Instead
of preventing partisan weaponization,
your department has engaged in a brazenly polit >> Oh,
it's just talking about Epste never prosecution
at the president's explicit direction. Maxwell, >> the
department has become President Trump's personal sword and shield
to >> Isn't that rough that I I can't name the I can't
pin the tail on the in the Trump administration and their allies.
I literally just I can't I can't find a way to pin the tail on
the There's just so many options. I keep it up. >> Go after
his ever growing list of political enemies and to protect himself,
his allies and associates.
My questions therefore focus on these two themes. hiding the
corrupt acts of his friends and prioritizing the political prosecution
of his enemies. So, let me start with the shocking allegations
of bribery and paytoplay.
Two weeks ago, four major media outlets reported that Tom Holman,
the president's top deportation official
working in the White House, took 50,000 in cash in a bag from
undercover FBI agents in September 2024,
just over a year ago. According to these reports, Hman indicated
he would facilitate securing contracts in exchange for money
once he was in office in a future Trump
Reportedly, this exchange was caught on tape. Rather than pursue
this investigation without fear or favor, the department and
the FBI under your leadership or that of your predecessor before
you confirmed quietly shut it down. Once news broke, your deputy
and FBI director issued a joint public statement confirming that
the Trump administration closed the investigation.
White House press secretary Caroline Levitt denied Homeman took
the 50,000.
He did. That's the That's the best part. Uh Caroline Levit says
no, he didn't take it. Right. Everybody else has been saying
no, I didn't do anything criminal. I didn't do anything, you
know, criminal at all. There's no criminal prose. Listen, I they
found I didn't do anything criminal. They never say, "No, he
didn't take the money. No, the money was returned. No, I I didn't
do anything criminal." >> Telling a reporter, quote, "Mr.
Holman never took the $50,000 that you're referring to, so you
should get your facts straight." So today, I hope you can help
us get our facts straight.
The is it not the duty of the Department of Justice to correct
the record of the executive okay of the executive branch of an
executive a White House official when they say, "Hey, no, he
didn't take the money." Okay. Are you are you going to tell me
also? Will you put it on the record here that he didn't take
the money? I'd love for you to do that. >> Was that true
what the White House press secretary said when she denied home
and took the money? Did he take the money?
Senator Schiff, as I stated earlier,
I was not in office. I was not confirmed when that was handled.
>> So, does that >> Deputy Attorney General Blanch
and Director Pat >> So, when this major corruption scandal
came about in newspapers, okay, MSNBC started reporting on it.
Every major newspaper picked it up. They all source Department
of Justice officials, okay? and they say there's a videotape
or audio tape of Tom Hman taking $50,000 in a grocery bag. You're
saying that as the head of the department that allowed that to
happen, the dismissal of that case without any questions being
asked. You didn't raise an eyebrow. You just sat there and went,
"Well, seems fine to
I mean, it's believable based on how stupid you seem on every
other question, but I just got to ask, why should we have an
incompetent attorney general like this? Okay. Why are you so
bad at your job? Don't you feel any embarrassment for being this
bad at your >> Tell said that there was no evidence that
Tom Hman committed a crime. Yet now you're putting his picture
up to slander
>> No, I'm putting
>> We're not Nobody's slandering him for committing a crime.
They're slandering him for selling influence for $50,000 that
he received as cash in a grocery bag.
That's what we're talking about. So tell me he didn't receive
that cash in a grocery bag or
stop calling it slander. One of the two. I'm not saying he committed
a crime. I'm saying he had a he had a huge ethical lapse that
would be embarrassing for any administration to deal with. Okay?
They would absolutely fire him to deal with the shame. You kept
him despite this shame and you are defending him now. Okay. But
nothing I'm not alleging anything illegal happened. You are the
person covering for him. putting his picture up showing an interview
he gave with I think Fox >> in which he was asked explicitly
about these allegations that he took a $50,000
>> And he refused to answer. He said he didn't answer the
question whether he took the money. So I'm asking you the question,
did he take the money? >> Senator Schiff, I answered that
>> You So
Pam Bondi by accusing them of slander.
Right. If you're going to accuse me of slander when I say he
took $50,000 in cash from a bag, you are telling me he didn't
take cash from a bag. That is your testimony in front of Congress.
And we will
and then if she tries to argue, well, what is slander? Define
slander for me. It's a knowing lie. You're saying I'm lying when
I say he took money in a bag. Therefore, you are saying he did
not take money in a bag >> multiple times. And frankly,
you know, >> well, I I I don't think with respect, I don't
think you did. But in case >> now I understand that you
are not intelligent enough to work that out on your own, Miss
Bondi, but I worked it out for you. I've explained it to you
now. So once again, is it slander or defamation when I say that
Tom Hman took $50,000 in a grocery bag from Cava?
>> I just didn't hear you. >> What is the answer?
Did he take the >> Senator Schiff, that happened prior
to my confirmation as you understand. But do you know I said
that? Do you know sitting here what >> All I know is that
Deputy Attorney General Todd Blanch
and FBI Director Patel said there was no case. And Caroline Levit
is one of the most trustworthy human beings I know. So she
was you worked for me, you would have been fired because you
were c censured by Congress for lying with your >> We can
stipulate to you can stipulate to all your personal attacks on
the Democratic members of the committee. personal attacks. You've
been attacking my FBI director. You've been attacking my office.
You've been attacking. But what we're interested in borders are
what we're interested in is the answer to these oversight questions.
colleague you were asked by attacking good people. >> A
regular order, madam chair, so I can ask a question. You were
asked by my colleague from Vermont
whether you will support providing a video or audio tape if it
exists of Mr. Mr. home and taking 50,000 in bribe money from
the FBI. Will you support a request by this committee to provide
that taper tapes to the committee? Yes or no? >> Senator
Schiff, you can talk to Director Patel about that. >> Well,
I'm talking to you about it. You're you're the you're the attorney
general. This will be your decision.
Will you support >> You have to tell me what is my decision,
what is not my decision. I said
>> dude, it is your decision. It literally is your decision.
You can You think you got a gotcha with Tom Hol
been out there fighting for our country since Donald Trump took
office?
>> Yeah. Except he took office after he accepted a bribe
and you guys instead of instead of dealing with that and firing
him, you kept him and then dismissed the case against him. That's
the problem, right? regardless of legality. The problem is this
guy took bribes from people in cash so it couldn't be traced
on the on the under the understanding or sorry based on the understanding
that he would provide government contracts to the people who
were bribing him. He did that and then when you guys found out
about it, you found out about an undercover investigation that
discovered him doing this. You decided to keep him, not fire
him and then dismiss the that is the problem. So I don't care
about criminality. We don't have to talk about criminality. Talk
about your ethical >> I'm trying to ask a question. Regular
order, please. Uh, and you don't have to defer to the FBI director
to pass the buck. So, I'm asking you, will you support a request
so that the committee or indeed I believe the American people
should be able to see that video or audio tape. Will you support
that >> Will you apologize to Donald Trump?
why
will you apologize to Donald Trump? Okay. Okay. D >> director
to pass the buck. So, I'm asking you, will you support a request
so that the committee or indeed I believe the American people
should be able to see that video or audio tape? Will you? >> It's
like so transparent. Hey, I think you guys are enabling corruption.
Uh, have you thought about apologizing to Donald Trump? She listen,
she knows JD Vance is the apple of Donald Trump's eye. She knows
that it's based on that JD. Have you thought about apologizing
to Mr. Trump for showing up not wearing a suit? Remember the
Zalinsky meeting? Okay, Pam saw that and she's like, "Oh, I'm
I'm stealing that one. I'm going to use that a couple months
from now." >> You support that request. >> Will you
apologize to Donald Trump?
>> I guess the answer is you won't support >> after
you now know that Joe Biden tried to cover up Biden's involvement.
Excuse me. Let me let me do this because
I think it's it's valuable
that the American people get a sense of of what you've refused
to answer today.
>> So, these are just some of the questions you refused
to answer, but or have answered with personal attacks on members
of this committee. You were asked whether you consulted with
career ethics lawyers as you promised you would do during your
nomination hearing when you approved the president receiving
a 400 million dollar gift from the Qataris. You refused to answer
that question. You were asked what who or what role you may have
played. >> You refused to answer whether or not you >> played
the role in asking the
>> Yes. Thank you. >> Trump's name be flagged in
any of the Epstein documents. I was thinking you refused to say
whether or not there was any coordination with Trump on indicting
James Comey on getting rid of Eric Cybert in District of Eastern
Virginia >> by the FBI. You refused to answer that question.
You were asked whether Homeman kept the $50,000.
>> Oh, I there's a better way to to explain this. She's
been asked repeatedly whether or not they are firing people for
their political positions that they've like kept to themselves
essentially or or political positions they've expressed when
it's like fine to do so like off duty and stuff. They're being
fired for things to try to make sure that the FBI, the DOJ is
loyal to Donald Trump. She's been asked multiple times about
how and why people have been fired and she just answers every
time I can't discuss personnel decisions. Even though that is
not a precedent. You fired somebody and you had a good reason
for doing it. You should say so. of bribe money. You refused
to answer that question. You were asked whether Holman paid taxes
on the $50,000 bribe money. You refused to answer that question.
You were asked, "Did career prosecutors
find insufficient evidence to charge James Comey?" You refused
to answer that
You were asked, "How are military strikes on these boats in the
Caribbean legal?" And you refused to even ask answer that question.
You were asked, "Excuse me. Excuse me. Um, you were asked,
did you discuss indicting James Comey with the president? You
refused to answer that question. You were asked, did you approve
the firing of antitrust lawyers who disagreed with the Hila Packard
merger? You refused to answer that question. You were asked
whether you support a restoration fund for violent insurrections,
insurrections to attack the capital on January 6. Refused to
answer that question. You were asked whether you were firing
career professionals, career prosecutors just because they worked
on January 6 question, the January 6 investigations. You refused
to answer that question. You were asked by my California colleague
whether you believe government officials like immigration official.
>> Uh WBY, I'm going to give you a week off and when you're
like less high or whatever is going on now, you can come back.
Okay. >> Have to abide by court orders. >> You wouldn't
even
what relevance that has to anything going on right now. You're
like clearly having a thing, having a moment. You have that moment.
>> This is supposed to be an oversight
>> These Excuse me. You can attack me after my time is
over. >> You've attacked all of us, including President
Trump. >> You can attack me later. And I I know you've
got plenty of canned attacks. We've heard them all day today.
>> Canned attacks on you. >> This is supposed
regular order, Madam Chair. I'm trying to speak. This is supposed
to be an oversight hearing of the Justice Department and it comes
in the wake of an indictment called for by the president of one
of his enemies.
This is supposed to be an oversight hearing and it comes in the
wake of revelations that a top administration official took $50,000
in a bag and this department made that investigation go
This is >> Is there even anything they can do for her refusing
to answer these questions? I don't really think so. It's just
basically it's like hold her feet to the fire, make her answer
in a way that points out how obvious the corruption is. Like
you can censure people. I think I think you could like also say,
"Okay, we could move to like a private place where you could
give us like actual testimony." But yeah, I don't think um I
unless you prove they're lying, it's very very difficult. I think
>> supposed to be an oversight hearing when dozens of prosecutors
have been fired simply because they worked on cases investigating
the former president. This is and now the current president >> fires
in California.
This is excuse me.
>> Did Adam did Adam Schiff do something? Did he deny like
some fire suppression funding in California? Is that where we're
going? This is supposed to be an oversight hearing
in which members of Congress can get serious answers to serious
questions about the riots in LA
about the cover up of corruption
about the prosecution of the president's enemies
when will it be when will it be when will it be that the members
of this committee on a bipartisan basis demand answers to those
questions? and and refuse to accept
lawyers. Refuse to accept
someone can and cannot refuse to accept personal slander
as an answer to those questions. >> Personal slanderized
to Donald Trump for slandering him. Personal slander. Senator,
um, >> may I ask unanimous consent, Madam Chair,
uh, to introduce into the record the statement of a thousand
former Justice Department officials who warned that the Comey
indictment is a democracy threatening abuse of How do people
like this sleep? I legitimately don't get it.
yeah, I don't know. I hope they don't sleep well. I hope I hope
Pam Bondie knows that like, trust me, if weaponization is a thing,
there will be
I feel like somebody's just got to start saying that like, okay,
weaponization's on the table and we're going to actually make
sure we have evidence, but holy, you people are all going down.
Like, we see all the corruption. You guys are done. Like, it's
so over >> power. May I also request unanimous consent
for the introduction to the record of 282 former career officials
at the Justice Department raising the alarm who were voluntarily
or involuntarily
forced to leave the department because of improper actions taken
by the Department of Justice. May I introduce with unanimous
consent the Justice Department manual that talks about when initiating
and declining charges are subject to impermissible.
>> I feel like we're going to start seeing um oh man
stuff's coming apart at the seams. >> Considerations. And
finally, Madame Chair, may I introduce the letter from Michael
Ben Ary, a career counterterrorism prosecutor, DOJ, a letter
he nailed to his door,
uh, which concludes
by urging officials to do the right thing for the right reasons,
to follow the facts on the law, and raises the alarm that the
decision to remove experienced career officials from US attorney's
offices, the FBI, and critical parts of DO DOJ undermines our
country's abilities to counterterrorist organizations, malign
nation state actors, and countless others that seek to harm our
nation and its citizens.
And he believes that the the priority is prosecuting the president
or are you rather than protecting the country? May I have unanimous
consent to enter these into the record?
>> Shift did just get like another 80 seconds of monologue
saying what he was entering into the record with unanimous >> Without
objection. >> Thank you. I yield back. >> Senator
Senator,
>> that was a that was a seasoned Listen, that was a seasoned
move right there. It was a seasoned veteran move to just like
talk about what he's entering with unanimous consent and just
go on another monologue for like 90 seconds. >> One thing
he entered in the record. I I just want to say that I believe
he he entered a letter by
200 and something former employees. Well, I believe the spokesperson
for that letter was also the spokesperson for Jack Smith. >> Senator
Brit.
Thank you, Madam Chair. General Bond. >> Okay, that is
it for the House Judi, sorry, the Senate Judiciary Committee.
That's it for what we're going to watch out of that today. All
right.
Oh, what a what a you know, what a comeback for Shifty Shift.
Okay. Great stuff. You love to see it. Okay, I'm switching it
up. We're going to go and do I I'm going to eat some food real
quick. What we're going to do while I eat some food is we're
going to go over Darius and Zena both went over their legal cases
recently. Okay, I've got all of that stuff to go over and I think
I'm going to do that cuz I would go to the Destiny docks, but
I I'm I got to eat.
okay. So, we'll go over the Destiny docks, but
I'm going to do Derry Zena first because I've got actual video.
Darius versus Zena legal battle.
Zena's cooked. I we're doing Destiny today. I think so. I think
I will. I think I just Listen, we need uh Listen, I need you
guys to dig deep, support, add more time to the stream. Okay,
I